the North Korean military says it is
working on plans to launch four missiles
toward the American territory of Guam
president trump pledged an unprecedented
US response if that happens the small
Pacific island has about 6,000 troops
stationed there it has an overall
population of more than 160,000 people
Lahm is also considered one of the most
strategically important US locations in
the region CBS News is the only network
to gain access to Anderson Air Force
Base
I travel there several weeks ago for CBS
n on assignment to see the preparations
for a potential clash with North Korea
we arrived here at Anderson Air Force
Base in Guam this wing is considered a
power projection platform we're about 20
100 miles away from North Korea but that
doesn't really matter because this base
can accept assets from anywhere in the
world and launch them and take the fight
to our enemies this base has the largest
stockpile of fuel and munitions in the
airforce we can respond to threats from
the Middle East Asia and across the
Pacific Colonel Sam White has spent his
career here among these bombers in a
worst case scenario how quickly can this
air fuel get up to speed so we stand
ready to respond to a wide range of
things at the president's call that's
the reason why we have the continuous
part of the president's mission is to
give the President of the United States
sovereign options against threats to the
US so we're ready today
and they've had to prove that multiple
times in recent weeks on July 29th the
day after North Korea's latest
successful ICBM launch two US b-1
bombers took off from this airfield and
flew over two thousand miles to the
North Korean border in a show of force
the b1 also known as the bone is capable
of carrying more arms than any other
bomber in the airforce and as its air
crews can attest it's also among the
louts especially being out here you get
to feel the rumble level
when everyone goes into a particular
region it sends a very strong message
that the United States means business
well our first step is deterrence
obviously however if the combatant
commander calls upon us the b1 is a very
credible lethal force what sets the bone
apart I think it's three things and it's
all three of them together speed
persistence and payload so we can get
where we're going fast we can then stay
there for a long time and we bring a lot
of bombs with us you're looking at what
Airmen call Hays igloo stretching along
this road for about half a mile 15
million pounds of net explosive
conventional munitions they're built by
the 36th munition squadron each of these
bombs weigh 2,000 pounds we generally
crank each one is out in about eight
minutes time eight minutes time yes sir
you can build one of these and which one
are we building today it's an advanced
penetrator often referred to as a bunker
buster it can actually penetrate
concrete and reinforce the event what
kind of force are we talking about when
we say you know 2,000 pounds
what kind of devastation are we looking
at if anything ever goes wrong please we
always play us broma safety evacuate
4,000 feet 4,000 feet yes sir due to
North Korea's difficult mountainous
terrain and deep bunkers these types of
munitions could be of vital importance
in the event of a conflict one of the
things that we heard over and over again
especially as the rhetoric has heated up
over the last couple of months we asked
time and time again to the airmen what
does this all mean and for them it
really doesn't mean anything they do
their jobs every single day every
commander every noncommissioned officer
and every airman we spoke to said that
they are prepared to do their job today
of course it's hard not to pay attention
to what's happening right now more fuel
than any other air base there and bombs
and more bombs
most air base and that is where the b1
is is strategically deployed to the
Korean Peninsula but they need kc-135s
to refuel them we had an opportunity to
go up there you see a kc-135 from the
Arizona National Guard they took us up
to see that refueling process we also
had a very really fascinating look at
the air operations center in
Hickam Air Force Base in Hawaii general
TJ Shaughnessy took us in there there
they can monitor any threat to the
Pacific Theater in real-time 52 percent
of the world which is when we hear from
the defense secretary the idea of
overwhelming force and deterrence
capability this is what you're
illustrating in this piece this is what
the US has in Guam in Hawaii ready to go
to face off this threat that we're now
paying so much attention to but that's
been there for so long absolutely a
general Shaughnessy said that one of the
reasons that they train every day one of
the reasons that you look at these
terrible instruments of war which is
what they are is to prevent any kind of
attack or any kind of conflict no one
that I spoke to wants to see it come to
that but if they need to fight if they
receive the order from the commander in
chief as everyone told me they're
prepared to fight tonight and to take
the fight to the north extraordinary
look inside yeah amazing that you got
that access Latimer very fortunately
that the military the Air Force
specifically allowed us that access yeah
well you can see our full report on CBS
n on assignment it airs Monday night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS and
our streaming network cbsn